certainly synergy there we speak almost
daily we're brothers that actually get
along and like each other and spend a
lot of time together time permitting we
started the bar wild life together but
here at it I was in the real estate
business at the time I didn't want to
run it he ran it we then went on to the
club and again I was investor I'm an
active investor but I didn't want to run
the day-to-day we subsequently parted
ways he went and opened a restaurant
called citrus with a gentleman Louie
Lanza as Josie's and a few other places
and I went on and still the I got out of
the real estate business and I was
starting to do restaurant consulting and
I opened a restaurant called flowers
which was on 17 street which was a
celebrity Mecca at the time he went on
in I flowers I had a chef I actually
fired a chef you know who tried to hold
me up one night which chefs do and my
heart and another chef named Jimmy
Bradley and he was a very very
up-and-coming young kid and when I
opened up this fast food place it's
called it's a rapid hip or soy Jimmy
became my partner was sort of overseeing
the food component even though he was
doing other things I was getting out of
that business I got a problem with my
two main partners in that business I
decided to leave and I sort of bequeath
Jimmy to my brother and they went ahead
and opened a very renowned New York
Times 2-star restaurant called with the
red cat which I invested him so I was
still involved with them but on a much
less involved way they went on to open
up another place called Harrison equally
successful then they opened up a place
called pot j which didn't do as well and
they opened up the mermaid inn I had my
brother and I had an opportunity bought
out of the other restaurants and he was
able to take over the mermaid in a
hundred percent other than giving him
some construction advice and being an
ear
I'm not involved in his businesses and
he's not involved in mine but he was
originally going to be my partner in
magnolia and when we were talking to
Lisa in the first few meetings he was
there as my partner and it was a
wonderful deal firm I was going to put
up most of the money he was going to
have a nice sizable chunk to run it and
he kept vacillating on whether to do it
or not and right now he calls it in the
history of the world the worst business
decision ever made because he chose not
to do it but I think in reality he did
the right thing and his dilemma was I
love running the floor conceptualising
new places being on the floor working
the people working the room etc and
that's where his true love the
restaurant businesses and if he had been
working with me magnolia he would have
been doing schedules for nine dollar an
hour workers that was selling cupcakes
and it didn't resonate with him and he
kept vacillating and saying i'm in i'm
out i mean i'm out and he finally said
he's out and from a purely financial
point of view bad decision but from a
human being living the life and having
to go summer every day for 10 hours and
live it was absolutely the right
decision fan because you should do what
you love and then you'll be successful
you